Speaker 1: This is super interesting and not
altogether surprising.
The Daily Beast has a fascinating piece, somewhat
lengthy, not not huge, but take a few minutes
to read about how Rudy Giuliani seems to have
the walls closing in around him in terms of
these investigations that are going on.
And Donald Trump seems to have abandoned him
completely, which is absolutely on brand for
Donald Trump.
This is a piece in The Daily Beast which we
will link to written by Adam Rawnsley and
asone when subsetting, which writes, In the
weeks since the feds raided Rudy Giuliani's
apartment and office in late April, close
to close allies have tried to ferry a slew
of emergency requests to former President
Donald Trump and his advisers.
But according to three people familiar with
the matter, Trump and his legal advisers and
confidants have been hesitant about swooping
in to help the embattled Giuliani, who for
years worked as Trump's personal attorney,
political adviser and attack dog understand
what's going on.
Rudy's in trouble.
The walls are closing in around Rudy.
They raided his home.
They raided his office.
It's looking really bad for Rudy.
And Rudy is sending these massive dumps for
lack of a better term of requests to Trump
and his advisers for help, for interference,
for whatever some kind of intervention.
And Trump is just ignoring it.
The Daily Beast piece goes on to say, Team
Trump's reluctance to intervene comes at a
time when federal investigators have ramped
up their probe into whether Julie.
Yoni's Ukraine related work during the Trump
era amounted to an unregistered and illegal
lobbying operation on behalf of foreign figures.
So far, no charges have been brought.
Trump's silence has led to simmering frustrations
among members of Giuliani's inner orbit, who
privately allege that the president's team
is working to convince him to hang Giuliani
out to dry in his hour of need.
That's another level, and that would be absolutely
compelling.
We've been keeping an eye, but not talking
too much about Donald Trump's blogs on his
website.
And so far he has not come to the defense
of Rudy Giuliani.
But he's also not hung Rudy Giuliani out to
dry.
I think that if this escalates and it gets
to the point where it's clear Rudy is going
to be charged, I do think Trump will publicly
abandon Rudy and say he was he was off script.
He was doing his own thing.
He was not representing me.
One person close to Giuliani said last week,
quote, It's a question now of whether or not
Trump wants to leave Rudy to fend for himself
or if they're going to take a stand against
this.
Right now, we don't know among the pleas like
what is Rudy asking for among the police have
been for Trump to issue a strong verbal or
written statement saying Giuliani's work during
the Trump Ukraine saga was done on behalf
of Trump.
There's no way in hell, Trump says that because
Trump needs to leave the possibility if Rudy
gets charged of saying the Ukraine stuff had
nothing to do with me.
I had a perfect phone call and that's it.
Whatever Rudy was doing, I don't know about
the other asks have been that Trump sign on
to a legal motion to have federal investigators
throw out any seized communications that Rudy
and his lawyers are arguing are covered by
attorney client privilege.
And further, there have been requests that
Trump and his team financially help Rudy in
his legal defense.
Apparently, Rudy's legal expenses are going
absolutely crazy now.
That's what the Rudy people want Trump to
do.
On the other hand, and this is a really great
piece that looks at both sides of this in
The Daily Beast to people close to Trump,
they write say they have urged Trump to lay
low and refrain from making too many statements
one way or the other.
These people have told Trump it's unclear
what the feds have and anything Trump says
could backfire on him and on Giuliani.
That is exactly why Trump would never come
out and say Rudy was working on behalf of
me because they don't know what they have
on Rudy yet.
And if it's really bad, if they have Rudy
dead to rights, Trump now saying everything
Rudy did, he did it for me.
It implicates Donald Trump.
So this shouldn't surprise anybody who understands
how Donald Trump operates.
Look at Trump with his voters.
Trump defends them.
They're beautiful people.
There's my African-American and the Hispanics
love me and the suburban women.
These are all great people as long as they're
useful to him.
But as soon as they're not like, for example,
on January 6th, Trump turned on the TV.
And he saw the rioters who are all trumpet's,
and he said, these people look kind of low
class, they're making me look bad, and then
he abandons them.
Trump grifting, what was it, 70 million from
his supporters for legal battles after the
November election that were never going to
go anywhere.
Trump scamming his supporters, saying, I will
fight this and I will audit that and do a
recount here.
And more than half the money went just to
pay off Trump's campaign debt.
Why?
Because at that point, the election was over.
The only way that these people were useful
to Trump was trying to grift some money out
of them.
And it's the same way with Trump's lawyers
and cronies.
He abandoned Michael Cohen.
And when Trump has political allies, he loves
them while they're allies.
As soon as they see something, say something
even mildly critical, Trump abandons them.
So the one thing about this that is that is
predictable and on brand is Trump's not going
to come to anyone's defense unless it's useful
to him.
And right now, coming out and saying Rudy
did great work and it was all for me that
possibly implicates Donald Trump.
They don't know how bad Rudy is in trouble
at this point in time.
One other interesting aspect from this Daily
Beast article which says, quote, In recent
weeks, Trump himself has argued behind closed
doors that he wouldn't want to say Giuliani
was doing all of the Ukraine work, which included
a transatlantic dirt digging expedition on
the Biden family on Trump's behalf.
Trump's reasoning is based on the president's
insistence that he didn't always know what
Giuliani was doing during the Ukraine effort
or concocting with his Ukrainian pals, several
of whom Trump has privately dinged as idiots.
So apparently this is something Trump is saying
privately.
It's actually possible that that is to some
degree true.
But that doesn't tell us Trump didn't have
a sense of what was going on.
Very often someone in a role as powerful as
president of the United States would be deliberately
kept out of the loop as to the specifics of
what his henchmen are doing.
And when you're in that position, you know,
you're being kept out of the loop.
Like in other words, you may you know, it's
a known unknown.
You know, you're not being told exactly what
Rudi's up to, you know, the gist of it, but
you're not being told the specifics in order
to keep you potentially out of trouble if
something exactly like this would happen.
So the last thing anyone would do in this
situation is to say, I knew everything he
was doing and he was doing it all for me.
Now, one last thing here, OK, that this goes
back to Trump's narcissism.
Some people are saying, obviously, Trump isn't
going to help someone who has mountains of
dirt on him because Trump's worried it will
come back on him.
But isn't there a risk that Rudy, if Trump
doesn't help him, will release all the dirt
he has on Trump? Trump doesn't think this
way.
Trump is a narcissist, Trump cannot conceive
of anybody turning on him in that way if they
did so what he's Donald Trump.
It's not like anything bad can happen.
Anything Donald Trump does in his mind is
legal and good because it's something he did
and that would never happen.
So I know you and I might say, you know, it's
a double edged sword because on one hand on
the one hand, Trump doesn't want to defend
Giuliani because that could come back to bite
him.
On the other hand, if Trump doesn't, Rudy
could release whatever dirt he has on Trump.
Trump, the narcissist doesn't think the dirt
Rudy has could really damage him in a serious
way.
That's what you have to remember about how
the narcissist thinks.
So we'll see what happens.
Let me know if you think there are charges
forthcoming for Rudy.
I think I just don't know.
And it's not because I don't think Rudy did
some horrible things.
It's similar to gaits.
We have a two tiered justice system in this
country.
We know that people in positions of power
often are not subject to the same circumstances
that other people are.
So I just I genuinely don't know what to expect
in terms of charges against Rudy.
But let me know your thoughts.